right for the left the only total
compliance total submission will do now
no one is better
than my next guest whose brand new book
addresses is head-on
here now ben shapiro host of the ben
shapiro show
author of the new book authoritarian
moment out
tomorrow ben congrats on the book it's
great to see you tonight
now we've discussed this a lot on the on
the angle but
the left wasn't just happy owning
entertainment higher education
now they're looking to take over the
military and other traditionally more
conservative spaces
what does this tell us
the renormalization laura of every
single major institution in america
american life is continuing a pace and
everybody can feel this by pulling data
literally the only people in america who
by broad numbers feel comfortable saying
what they think are people
who exist on the radical left if you're
not on the radical left you have to
think twice about it you're afraid of
being socially ostracized you're afraid
of being fired
and it's because the institutions
themselves have been changed and changed
from the inside
all it takes is about 20 percent of
people at any given institution
to renormalize the institution along
their lines as long as they are
intransigent as long as they are very
loud
and so long as there is cowardice within
within the institution
you've seen it happen in a wide variety
of institutions all the way up to and
including
places that conservatives thought were
relatively safe corporate america for
example or the military
and as we see these stories rolling out
there will be blowback
we just hope that the blowback isn't too
little too late here
now ben to your point um the democrats
are already paying a price now according
to this new piece in politico
they may be losing ground on this quote
school equity plans they're writing that
people are scared democrats appear to be
underestimating parents anger
in places where critical race theory is
top of mind objections to new equity
plans are not the sole province of
conservatives
but expand extend to many moderates and
independent voters as well
uh ben they're just realizing this and
if they're doing it to the military with
the woke-ism
the schools you're running into mama
bears there in school
and daddy bears well that's exactly
right i mean they can boil the frog only
so long
before people actually start to realize
that the frog is boiling and they start
to push back the boiled frog eventually
does try to jump out of the pot
we are at that point in the educational
system all the parents who basically had
said i'm sending my kid to school i'm
going to leave them there and
all these good-hearted teachers they're
going to civilize my kids make them
better american citizens
they're beginning to realize especially
after the pandemic especially after
having to zoom into class and see what
teachers are actually teaching their
kids
that this is a bad idea that the heads
of our institutions don't have their
best interests at heart
and you're starting to see that silent
majority that silent middle
the people who up until now have been
sort of conflict at verse
starting to say well i can't be conflict
at verse anymore because you've not left
me the opportunity
to be conflict diverse either i stand up
and i protect my kids or i watch as my
kids get perverted by
ideologies that are blatantly
anti-american like crt
now uh one final point ben and it goes
to the point of your book
now you have the adl the anti-defamation
league
that are are working with paypal
to try to stop funding so-called hate
groups
now people think kkk okay but that's i
mean it's not really defined
what the quote hate groups are going to
be what does this say
to conservative organizations or others
that could just be thrown into some list
just because they disagree on
some basic issues well i mean pick your
poison on what issue
what does this tell us what direction
are we going in
this this is the scariest thing i think
that's happening right now is the
perversion of neutral service providers
in pursuit of a political end by the
left we saw this when parlor was kicked
offline by amazon web services
after january 6th and now you're seeing
it with paypal which is supposed to be
again a neutral service provider you
just use it to pay your bills
and now they're saying okay we're going
to team up with the adl which is an
overtly left-wing organization
that is very broadly defining the kind
of content that they're seeking
to target authoritarianism doesn't just
have to come from the government it's
not just people at the government level
telling you what to do
it's the hijacking of institutions that
matter in your life to ostracize you
from your social community
and then push you outside of the
boundaries of normal everyday life
that's dangerous stuff it polarizes the
country
the left is doing it every single day
ben thank you
everyone go buy the book the
authoritarian moment
is out tomorrow and ben great to see you
congrats
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else